il y en a assez de se la jouer chacun
pour soi chacun de son côté
la mutuelle des ménages prévoyante ce
sont des êtres humains et vous avant
tout en cas d'urgence vous pouvez
contacter notre assistance 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7
parce que votre santé n'attend pas une
mutuelle qui répond toujours présent
c'est ça une mutuelle qui va bien
cliquez et vérifier le dès maintenant
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
check up votre émission santé et
bien-être
au programme dans ce numéro l'union
régionale des professionnels de la santé
a réuni les jeunes médecins pour les
inciter à s'installer dans les yvelines
nous vous expliquerons pourquoi et puis
nous nous sommes vus à une session de
formation aux gestes qui sauvent
organisé dans un établissement scolaire
t pour terminer nous vous proposons de
découvrir deux médecines douces en
compagnie de monique rizzo nous l'avons
suivi dans un conte de chi kong et
durant
mais tout d'abord inciter les jeunes
médecins à s'installer dans les villes
c'est le but des journées découverte de
la santé organisé par l'ump s l'union
régionale des professionnels de la santé
à l'ufr santé simone veil de
l'université saint quentin en yvelines
le département a connu une baisse de 16%
du nombre de généralistes
entre 2009 et 2015 on regarde tout de
suite un reportage de mélanie poker
comment travailler en libéral ou
s'installer dans un territoire quand on
débute dans le métier
ce sont les réponses que sont venus
chercher médecins sages femmes
infirmiers ou encore interne ya un réel
besoin
dans les yvelines comme en france de
façon générale qui est des médecins qui
s'installent
il y avait il ya 30 ans 80 % des
étudiants diplômés s'installer en
médecine libérale et aujourd'hui ils
sont 13% à s'installer en libéral sur
saint quentin en yvelines les personnels
de santé dit de recours tels que les
médecins généralistes les
kinésithérapeutes ou encore les
dentistes sont quatre pour 5000
habitants un chiffre dans la moyenne
nationale à l'échelle de l'agglomération
l'institut de promotion de la santé peut
accompagner les professionnels
intéressés ce qu'on a pu faire pour
l'instant c'est c'est repérer ces
indicateurs
c'est un appui administratif au montage
des dossiers notamment par exemple les
diagnostics territoriaux des études de
faisabilité donc aider à mettre en place
et puis faciliter les liens avec
d'autres professionnels les centres
hospitaliers etc
sur territoire sur l'agglomération il
n'y a pas de communes saint quentinois
se considérer en déficit mais celle de
trappes est tout de même classée par la
rs l' agence régionale de santé
comment fragilité sur l'offre dite de
premier recours dans le cadre du plan
gestes qui sauvent relancé par la
préfecture les services de secours de 78
organise durant tout le mois de février
pour former aux actions à conduire en
situation d'exception
ces sessions gratuites sont également
dispensés au sein de certains
établissements scolaires sur volonté du
chef d'établissement
patrick jacques de dixmude s'est rendu à
une de ces séances au lycée rené
descartes de montigny le bretonneux et
je sors je sors n'en regarde de l'autre
côté il faut que tu puisse regarder sa
poitrine se soulever masser défibriller
ou poser un garrot ces gestes auparavant
réservé aux professionnels vont
s'étendre au grand public dans ce lycée
de montigny le bretonneux
la direction s'est impliqué dans une
session de formation aux gestes qui
sauvent et c'est une opération très très
utile je pense que ça va nous permettre
de sensibiliser les élèves en cas
d'événement grave
parallèlement donc à la mise en place du
ppms du plan de mise en sûreté
dispensés par des bénévoles est mise en
place avec les services de la direction
academy
cette formation ne se substitue pas au
psc1 au programme des gestes à adopter
en situation d'exception comme posé un
garrot
on a vu comment protéger se protéger et
protéger la victime sur une scène
d'accident comment passez une alerte
elle par quels moyens etc on april a
donc tout à tout ce qu'il a touché un
petit peu à la traumatologie de
l'attentât c'est à dire les saignements
les plus graves les victime inconsciente
qui respire ou qui ne respire pas donc
après les massages cardiaques et
l'utilisation du défibrillateur venus
volontairement chacun des élèves reçu un
diplôme à la fin de la formation
je suis contente parce que je sais que
je pourrai sauver des vies et je savais
pas le sarrasin maintenant j'essaie les
gestes je pense que c'est bien pour
l'avenir parce que du coup tout le monde
est sauvé et tout le monde fait un héros
une formation qui répond à une demande
suite aux attentats du 13 novembre de
nombreux français avaient exprimé le
souhait de connaître les gestes utiles
pour sauver des vies en dehors de ces
formations en milieu scolaire la
préfecture des yvelines a organisé 83
cession gratuite pour le mois de février
sur le territoire de nos jours les
médecine thérapeutique orientale sont de
plus en plus utilisés en occident à
l'exemple du shiatsu
cette technique de thérapie manuelle
d'origine japonaise inspiré du massage
chinois à saint cyr l'école monique
pizzo et praticienne professionnelle en
shiatsu et nous a ouvert les portes de
son cabinet
le shiatsu c'est une technique de
massage japonais
donc c'est un massage on travaille avec
les pousse les paumés les coudes on fait
des pressions sur tout le corps et s'est
basé sur l'acupuncture donc c'est en
résumé un genre de digitopuncture on
travaille avec le poids du corps et la
respiration équilibrer les énergies de
son corps avec le shiatsu cette méthode
de massage thérapeutique basée sur le
ying et le yang fonctionne sur un
système simple du donneur et du receveur
le shiatsu est avant tout un partage il
ya 365 points en acupuncture
donc en fait ces points ils suivent le
cir des circuits d'énergie qu'on appelle
des méridiens je travaille delà de la
tête jusqu'aux orteils l'intérêt du
shiatsu c'est que c'est une technique
globale un travail global dont moi je
parle pas de technique je fais un
couteau d'un art parce que la façon de
faire la pression c'est ce qui fait la
différence entre un praticien et un
autre pour son chien dessous monique
travail avec le poids du corps la
respiration et sur table chaque
praticien exerce selon son enseignement
je viens rechercher un petit peu
d'énergie de dynamisme et c'est ce que
me donne les séances de shiatsu pendant
voilà pendant quelques quelques temps
quelques mois et j'essaye de vue de
faire deux séances à l'année voilà pour
me rebooster un petit peu utilisé
généralement en tant que médecine
préventive en 2015 cette discipline a
reçu une reconnaissance professionnelle
du titre de spécialiste en chips ou au
répertoire national des certifications
professionnelles
partons désormais à la découverte du chi
kong
cette gymnastique traditionnelle
chinoise fondée sur la maîtrise de
l'énergie vitale une méthode destinée à
la santé et au bien-être du corps
nous avons assisté à une séance de
formation en compagnie de monique pidio
à saint cyr l'école
améliorer sa santé son bien-être
intérieur en faisant corps avec la terre
le chi kong littéralement exercice de
maîtrise de l'énergie vitale est une
méthode chinoise qui regroupe des
techniques de gymnastique méditation et
de respiration à saint cyr l'école
monique pizzo transmet son savoir faire
chaque semaine
le chi comme c'est le travail de
l'énergie par les mouvements donc on
stimule le système énergétique du corps
en faisant des mouvements avec les bras
les jambes on se reconnecte avec son
corps pour atteindre l'état de chicons
qu'un travail d'installation est
nécessaire un travail qui passe par
cette gymnastique physique jusqu'à
l'harmonie totale des mouvements du
corps et de l'esprit avec la terre quand
on voit un arbre c'est vraiment l'image
du tic ont l'arbre il est enraciné donc
ya les racines et il a les feuilles qui
partent ces branches qui partent vers le
ciel et nous on fait partie de la nature
donc on est comme un arbre donc il faut
qu'on recrée ses racines dans le
ressenti des racines se fait par le
relâchement du poids du corps monique
parle de plusieurs types de chi kong
celui du singe ou de l'éléphant une
technique très symbolique qui aident à
la représentation du corps dans l'esprit
chaque chi kong
il ya un effet particulier moi je me
sens particulièrement bien détendu zheng
he bien prendre conscience de son corps
que son énergie et puis après ben oui à
serbian être très agréable
une méthode qui se décline en plusieurs
variantes petit doit être pratiquée
régulièrement pour être bien maîtrisé
pour monique le chi kong plus qu une
gymnastique du corps est un art de vie
et pour terminer voici l'agenda
tout d'abord à guyancourt un rendez vous
scientifique pour les enfants autour des
cinq sens comment fonctionnent nos yeux
nous avons nous tous la même sensation
au toucher
autant de questions auxquelles répondent
les ateliers proposés pour y participer
rendez vous le 13 février à la maison
cartier théodore monod et puis pour
savoir comment bien manger à petit prix
direction magny les hameaux
le 19 février afin de connaître toutes
les astuces pour remplir saignements son
panier à moindre coût mais pour finir je
tiens à vous rappeler qu'il est
important de se rendre deux sessions de
formation les gestes qui sauvent
pour connaître toutes les sessions les
horaires les dates et les inscriptions
rendez vous sur le site de la préfecture
voilà check up c'est maintenant terminé
quant à moi je vous donne rendez-vous
dans deux semaines pour un prochain
numéro
et d'ici là prenez soin de vous
à